good
morning Millennials happy Monday good
morning Lauren welcome to the toast
welcome back to the toast I should say
thanks for having me I'm so excited to
be here again I'm so excited that you're
here one because I just need like my
quarterly beauty review with you and I
know the toasters do too because it's
like every time you come you teach us so
much we use like the next four months to
practice what you preach and now we have
fresh questions for you so I will get to
them and like I was just at my old
college and I was doing this whole thing
about how I used to like wear my makeup
and like my face hasn't changed at all
since college but like I wish someone
one of just giving me a lymphatic
massage you know well seeing you I
haven't seen you so I'm an outside
perspective hey I'm telling you your
skin is looking so glowy thank you
and you know it's not even I do the
massages every day but it's like it just
has affected the way I put on my
moisturizer every day so like every day
I just put it on like this and the end
dream I know three more tea and you know
what I drained I tried to drain my
husband's face okay cuz I brought I
whipped out the Jade roller and he was
like what's that and he made me do it
for him and then I was like actually
just do it with your hands and we did it
together so thank you so it's like a
couple's thing now well now he knows
about it so maybe he'll do it for
himself
what did he drain during the wedding uh
I don't think so but you know that
should come in like the barbers package
you know like the barber should don't
they give you like a face massage and
then they slap you and yes yeah nice
effect like a ten step routine so he
doesn't need that but we can't start
your husband slow yeah a starter pack
did the toen perfect well welcome back
to the show we haven't been here since
Thursday so much has happened since we
posted our episode with Erika Jayne
which was just beyond premium that's
with her I literally do watch Beverly
Hills okay cuz we can also on talk about
Beverly Hills but I literally felt like
Teddy Mellencamp in the room cuz I was
like so intimidated by her but it was
like she wasn't being scary it was just
me being a weaker woman you know what I
mean no she's she's such a strong
presence I can imagine and she's such a
ballbuster in the best way that I could
see what you mean yeah I was larger than
mine aw did you see what she wore to
Marc Jacobs I did so good she's so
perfect I mean I want to get your
thoughts on what's going on how serene
Beverly Hills
her skin is premium it's delicious
looking oh my god yeah
it's good stuff yeah that was big that
you guys interviewed it's major I know
I'm high light of life and I had like
read her book and I was being such a
nerd like my history major like sites
and sources I was like you said this
once what does it mean her book was so
good so good I loved it well very cool
and then we had our toast one-year
anniversary celebration on the Thursday
night and our official one-year
anniversary of the toast is tomorrow
congratulation thank you so have a
really fun show for you guys Claudia
we'll be back we'll have our merch store
pop up with our best sellers and I'm
just excited to look back on the year oh
and then this weekend I just suffered
from like one of the worst hangovers of
all time you're probably just tired from
planning a wedding because that wedding
was the royal wedding oh my God thank
you
I mean I've never seen anything like I
agree that I'm still tired from planning
a wedding
I thought the content on Instagram like
your layout and everything was the dress
it was so good it was a happy best
wedding like if anyone needs wedding
tips on Instagram I went back to my
photos and I was like [ __ ] I didn't do
it like you I mean it was it was bigger
than Megan Markel getting married oh my
god thank you
but um no but then I look like I
literally remember when I started
planning my wedding you came on the show
in like June and we were just talking
about weddings and I couldn't even get
my hands around wedding planning like I
didn't know where it was gonna be
herbicides or anything you were telling
me how you just like went down to Mexico
and got married with just your family I
was like that is the dream it is there's
pros and cons of everything your wedding
was like an exhibit I mean you're gonna
look back on that and the pictures and
all your different outfit changes it's
true and I never intended to be a bride
with so many how fits like that it all
happened at the last minute it was cozy
yeah it was it was a good time it was
made all the work worth it and now I
have everything I love like now talking
about it was people but when people
would ask me about it before I was like
I have nothing to say it's in your
scrapbook it took everything out of I
took everything out of yeah I was
looking at you and I was like how is she
planning this incredible wedding and
producing all this content at the same
time oh my god Thanks well then the
wedding became the content you know yes
yes I did it work yeah I made it work
for me I think I posted like
30-something pictures and I ran out of
pictures now I have to like go through I
want to post more but it's like I have
to now choose the ones that it like at
them edited and whatever everyone loved
it the whole guy I'm in the group and
everyone loved it they were all talking
about
a single outfit in detail and I mean it
was just amazing this is fun tanks well
yeah and that was fun times cuz you're
here I'm here there's so much I want to
get your opinion on mostly Kourtney
Kardashian's website we got to talk
about we'll get into it okay well
welcome to New York how's your trip in
so far our trips been a great we got in
at 12 and Michael decided that we needed
to walk to get pizza so I had three
pieces of pizza to kick off the trip
thanks for that facial swelling and
bloat and so we woke up and got ready
and now we're hearing
we're busy all week where did you get
pizza Lynette us Lynette oh I think it
I've heard of it if a New Yorker says no
no no like I think I've passed but in
New York if you just wherever you are
get pizza like you don't have to go out
of your way okay like you don't you
travel for pizza like there's $1 P 2
across Peachtree from my apartment if I
ever want pasta that's all right I
didn't need pizza at 12 o'clock at night
ever
I don't know you're probably not hungry
today a true true I might do a little
fasting yeah you know what I did the
other day and I thought like maybe I
wanted to get your take on it
I got an IV a like an IV drip okay I got
it for my hangover because I was on
death's door and it brought me back to
life I was still then I just had like a
normal person hangover but then I was
thinking like I would love to do this
one I feel just a little shitty because
it probably makes you feel really good
what are your thoughts on IVs I totally
love it just go to someone that really
knows what they're doing that's you know
certified like you don't want a group on
IV you know what I mean hey because
there's there's been a lot of stories of
someone going to some random person and
it's I mean you're sticking a needle
right I didn't go to a random I went to
the IV doctor perfect online perfect hey
I also hate needles more than life
itself and so I have to like look away
and lay down and do orange juice and a
banana and like the whole gamut got it
okay then you know what self wasn't so
bad and I was just I would have done
anything so and it made it made a level
deal oh yeah I would do it again I
believe it's taken me this long to do it
like Stassi does it all the time she
always talks about it on their podcast
and I feel like I Kim does it like I
think she did it before the Met Gala
like just like for hydration
yes um yep
yeah I think the Vanderpump rules cool
are always doing because they probably
get like the worst hangovers of anyone
totally like hope like for you James
needs like 10 like and also or like Jax
like cuz he's like the oldest and like
I'm 26 and my hangovers are like enough
to make me really never drink like for
six months
Jax is looking pretty snatch though
right now he's drinking I don't think I
think he's looking good Britney they oh
wait they all like look really good yeah
and then I think it's really just when
they film they just have to like commit
yeah you have to go and you have to like
drink I feel like that's part of the job
yeah which sounds like anger is like
part of the job totally I mean it could
be more servers jobs out there but
anyways okay so let's get into the Fast
Five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast so the sooner we
do that the sooner we can get to all of
your questions for more on all of my
personal questions the iPad is frozen
but it's okay because our story is just
about the red carpet at the ACMs
American Country Music Awards were last
night I personally didn't watch because
I spent all weekend catching up on Game
of Thrones do you watch I am NOT up to
date on Game of Thrones but I watch
where are you I want to say I'm at the
second-to-last season oh okay but you
can ruin it for me I'm not like one of
those people or you can't ruin it like
when I die so I've watched it i watch
like I'm all caught up and then this
weekend my husband died we were like
let's watch the last season so we can
get ready for the new season premiering
on Sunday and we started watching all
season we were only three episodes in
and we're like but we only have four
more left and like we need more so we
started all the way from the beginning
ooh that's a commitment it's a
commitment and now we're at we're on
season 2 now and it is just the greatest
show that's ever been made in the
history of the planet and like when I
was watching it six years ago and like
there's all this torture of them going
like beyond the wall and it's so gray
and boring and like gratuitous and it's
like why are they wasting our time it
said when you watch it back now it's
like there's not one moment that or one
word spoken
that's gratuitous or or it doesn't need
to be there like every single scene like
is leading you to a greater answer
teacher it's so strategic it's a game
smart of Thrones it's a game of throne
and then the game of
you either win or you die anyway so
that's been my whole weekend and I
haven't known anything that's been going
on in pop culture and I have to be
honest has been really nice yeah you
took a little break yeah I beat you at a
three-day hangover and you watch Game of
Thrones I did what could be better than
statics massage my husband's face and it
was a nice looking good he's looking
good you should do like a before and
after oh yeah I should do that for
myself but I feel like it's just like
it's like anything else just you have to
be consistent it's like not one massage
is gonna change your face but it yeah
everyday like you'll be better totally
totally I feel like your husband too is
like let it's more shy than you on
social media like oh he's so private I
like that though yeah I like it too and
then every he's always down to like do
stuff with me when I ask him to UM but
everyone's around be like no don't ho
sadder like this or that and that's me I
like that yeah if he doesn't like hinder
me from doing my job yes but he's not
like perfect thirsting out what a match
and we try you know opposites attract
the thirst list and the thirst monster
anyways the ACMs were last night and the
country the women of country music
really showed up on the red carpet we
have Carrie Underwood Kelly Clarkson
Kacey Musgraves Nicole Kidman Marin Mars
did you see her dress I really like
Casey's dress I don't know if it's a
dress because it's like a laser movement
yeah we I didn't see that what's that
this is Christian sick Mary Morrison
Christian Siriano and I think it's like
my favorite dress I've ever seen I would
look so cute on you oh my god thank you
when I saw it I was at dinner with my
sister-in-law and her fiance and I
literally gasped and they were like
what's wrong and I was like I need
another wedding I know sorry just for
that dress let's do another suit again
okay sounds good we'll renew our vows
okay she looks amazing yeah she looks
amazing caso it's amazing they're my two
favorites I also thought Miranda Lambert
looked amazing like in a lovely color
yeah I'm here for it you know what
they're looking amazing Kelly Clarkson's
looking good Kelly Clarkson is like
snatched to the gods these days she
always looks good Carrie Underwood yes
Carrie Underwood always looks good she's
always showing like a leg yeah there's
just a glamorous Bunch
we met sang at the awards I didn't catch
it but um cool Lauren Bushnell was there
with her man oh gosh
nice girl there were some other notable
red-carpet moments couples first of all
Colton and Cassie stepped out on the
carpet together okay Colton had been
like teasing her dress for like on
Twitter being like this is the hottest
dress where I get all my Colton oozes
from your grill I didn't want you know I
get all the news from the grill that's
all you really need
honestly I never seen people cover stuff
so much like it's it's so efficient hey
go in there and get all my news yeah and
they're cute Cole's hitting Cassie
they're a little like extra on Instagram
but they're young and thirsty and so
let's give it to them yeah I'm happy
they seemed really happy and that's
what's important with social media I
feel like sometimes you never know like
the intention of going on the show which
is fine right like we all have to work
you know so I respect the hustle
I respect the hustle too and they like
look cute at the ACMs adorable yeah they
match I appreciate the effort now
there's a couple that stepped out on the
red carpets of ASEAN so you might not
know either of them okay I just think
it's most a random pairing and I'm
shocked by it
you ever watch wags yes Barbie yes just
debuted her relationship with Cole
Swindell I don't know who that is show
me a picture he's a country music star
I think he's like okay look they're cute
they're cute but like I love how they
save it for the red carpet I know I'm
really so surprised by this I ship I
love like I love her from the show and I
love him and I love his music and like
so therefore I love the both of them but
I didn't see this coming she liked it
was married to a hockey player she was
married to a hockey player he was chatty
apparently I'm sure he was allegedly he
was shady really yeah what do you know I
just know that he was a little cheating
yeah that's what I call him a little
cheating you know Aaron he they seemed
really cute like it was really
surprising when they got divorced on the
show in the way that it went down was
just weird and then I thought she would
see she was eating someone else I I
stalked on Instagram but now she's
eating : she's got a beautiful body
yeah with her in Beverly Beach but see
you know her you know her work I know
her work her ponytail she is the girl on
Beverly Hills it was in that photo shoot
with her e-everyone photo she in bathing
suit how could be and now she's
Cole Swindell and I'm here for it I'm
here for it - isn't that cute yatta
skill I feel like I look how he we're
hot - I like a baseball hat you know
yeah that's like the new cowboy the
modern cowboy hat yeah it's baseball
when Michael needs to loosen it up with
like the clothes and stuff I say throw
in a baseball hat you know if you had a
baseball hat on with this blazer yeah it
would it would be like a different look
it's a different vibe mirror tennis shoe
ooh yeah yeah maybe the boots weren't
the move today
that is what the kids are wearing no
it's good it's good you look like ready
for anything
and it's like dress for the job you want
not the job you have even though that's
what I did today but usually I'm like
totally you're honest i nia a little
like yeah I just want to die pay for you
and I have a busy day so I just wanted
to be wearing flat shoes so that I'm not
being slowed down it's perfect you're
inspiring like my next look oh my god
you're inspiring - Oh everyone's loving
your blazer by the way it's Zara and
it's like 50 bucks then I found it on
eBay recently yes recently I saw I was
in Switzerland and a lot of the working
girls were wearing sequins ooh
and they looked very fab and I thought
oh my god I need sequins so I went on
eBay go on eBay and Google sequin Zara
blazer and there's like 20 different
options Wow yeah I'm just saying sequins
are gonna be in for 2019 cool yeah I
can't wait you need like pink sequin oh
my god yes like a green sequin shoe like
for the morning toast you know yes yeah
and it like your pants - I love a wide
leg this is a revolve pant Norma
something revival to school but these
are like the pants that you can just
like let everything hang out you know
what I mean you gotta like suck the
thing you also look so polished my
favorite type of pant
nothing better than getting in the car
and just letting everything like it
feels like sweatpants but you look like
you're wearing trousers perfect trip
you're on to something anyway so that's
as far as I research about the ACMs
because like I said I'm literally in
Game of Thrones like I'm dreaming about
like my dreams are like I'm in Game of
Thrones but I think that's what it's
this whole other world so now that's
just the ramen it's gonna be her
I mean Daenerys it's like just
everything goddess and game but Erica
Jane of Game of Thrones
yeah and they ship her in time snow even
though their niece and nephew I mean
aunt and nephew
whatever whatever door there it's like
that of that world and like that's
better than brother and sister so I
think that they might could still end up
together
I don't know and uh oh speaking of
nephews do you watch SNL no cuz they
hate God I every time I come on the show
I know I barely like I only watch in and
out and I watch they had this scatter
sketch on Saturday night so I'm obsessed
with Claudia's dog Theo
amazing fu sneech s he's my nephew and I
just I love him so much in like be nice
to be on Housewives of New York he
really does
he's my pride and joy in this world and
like I'm always just talking about like
and appreciation how important it is
especially human and girl dance it's
just an important thing and I feel like
ants are so underappreciated and on SNL
this week they had a nephew pageant okay
and I literally thought it was like
someone went into my brain
I'm like cooked up my weirdest idea and
put it on the sand and I just I felt
really hurt so Thank You Colin Jost
for being a toaster and being so
supportive of us all this year
let's do you need more appreciation yeah
right I'm Anna I need more appreciation
for human yeah human
that's exciting yeah or also dog no no
but I think he moves probably
technically more exciting then dog right
well that's what I always say to Chloe
it's like I look Theo's so much like
there's not a bit of me that could love
him anymore and I just can't imagine how
I'm supposed to love something more when
you have a child
technically what Claude ever let you
take the O for like a week oh yeah she's
up for nephews weekend now she's let me
before and I took him in January because
my husband's had a huge dog person but
he's really come around recently but
when he went on his bachelor party
and Claudia was gone on tour for the
weekend I had a weekend with Theo and
her the greatest weekend perfect um
but ever in my apartment now we're
moving so it hasn't been feel friendly
moving stressful you did wedding and
then a move we were gonna stay in our
permanent here but that actually would
have been more stressful because we just
didn't have we just outgrew it like this
was ever meant to be more than a year
then we were like you know what we like
it we'll stay I have a moving tip so we
just moved and it was horrific like a
horrific move because we moved from San
Diego to LA why was it so horrific like
I need specific I think it's because we
change cities like I don't know it's
just such a transition and we the type
of house we moved into is very different
than the type of house we lived in in
San Diego and my advice is seriously I
know that it's marine whatever Marie
Kondo condo if it doesn't bring you joy
get rid of it so now like every morning
I wake up and like go in the bathroom
and I'm like that doesn't bring me joy
donating it that doesn't bring me joy
giving it to my sister I do it with
everything and our house like the stuff
has just completely minimalized which is
I can't explain it it's so liberating to
not have so much stuff should I watch
the show too like the eyes fire use your
move as an opportunity to like eat
clutter and honestly if you look at it
like that it will make it so much less
stressful
we've been intending to use the move up
it's an opportunity to declutter because
we're both very cluttered and like we
both have so much stuff like I have so
much stuff and I think actually Zach
might have more exact stuff can go
missing slowly like like we don't need
these sunglasses that make you look like
the three by Michael like things kind of
like like I just can disappear and go
like don't do the donation bin for me
it's like you can keep anything that you
actually wear like even if I don't like
it what if they wear it though and it
cycles I don't if you're wearing it the
time my problem is all the clothes I
just sit there that are like if
anything's actually hung up it means
that you don't wear it okay you know
okay if you hear that maybe they think
we need to watch that show together
before we move yeah watch it inspiration
totally but now I think that makes so
much sense exactly like I have so many
clothes that like I feel compelled to
keep but they don't spark joy in me like
you're not gonna and land on your
Instagram feed and they're not not
sparking joyed they're out right and my
other thing is if I haven't worn them in
a whole calendar year then I didn't wear
them in this season they were intended
for and I'm
go and wear them and then sometimes
they're like nobody just didn't fit into
it this fall but it's like no next of
all if I'm slim I'm not wearing that
thing from two seasons ago like I'm
gonna get me clothes cuz I'm like I
deserve it the worst is when you have an
alpha that you've had for so long and
you're like oh I can imagine me in that
pastel sky-blue coat like sipping an
expresso in the South of France and you
keep saving it for that moment and then
it doesn't like know it that's there and
sits there and sits there I don't
believe in saving outfits like if you
have something like I hate like when you
have an outfit in mind for something
you're like no but I want to save it for
something bigger it's like no one that
something bigger comes around you're
gonna go buy something hundred forget
that you have it and this outfit will
lose its opportunity yes trade Z is
amazing and soaz Poshmark so you to sell
your clothes I was on parchment for a
really long time and now it's like I
have a pile of things that I need to re
like add to Poshmark but I just haven't
gotten around to it but when I moved
like I've been saying everything for
like when I move it make sure it sparks
joy when you move it or else it's not
worth moving that is such a good theory
excite so Michaels that are like utility
clothes and they don't spark joy and I
don't wear them yeah and only keep the
stuff that like looks good on you I was
keeping all this stuff that was not
flattering the figure it's a whole like
we need you know like the pants that are
not looking cute yeah it rid of it wow I
need to watch the show it's like I'm
inside I haven't even seen it yet it's a
good show okay speaking of inspiration
pitbull and tony robbins team up for a
new fitness studio I don't think there's
two more inspiring people on the planet
or random after pairing up to motivate
fans around the country pitbull and Tony
Robbins are ready for another round and
this time they're bringing their boxing
gloves the Latin pop star who has
previously appeared with Robbins on his
seminar tour is joining the motivational
speaker in launching grit bx2 ng vixen
egg a new fitness studio in downtown New
York City the duo will serve as brand
advisors and investors to the studio
opening in June page six has exclusively
learned
quote my life is about working with
people to change their bodies change
their relationships and change their
lives Robbins said in the statement to
page six grit book snug will provide a
space and experience unlike any other I
think this is like really cute I am
really about collaborations that are
contrasting uh-huh like I really think
that the next five years is about you
know they paired like the
G with misguided like things that you
wouldn't think I think is it's really
genius
so of course you don't think of pitbull
and Tony Robbins together no but when
you put it together it's like it's it's
combining their audiences they have
different audiences in a really cool
unique way right it's like Nick Jonas
and Priyanka Chopra like they to me like
where's that is that's the only room but
now what is really room they say makes
so much sense to me I've been I'm
literally like been following the Jonas
Brothers and I was never a Jonas
Brothers fan do I need to get on like go
back and start listening no no no
because they like I feel like so much of
what's good about them now is like the
love that you had for them before okay
so and now it's like exciting so it's
like to bring my team Thrones like
Sophie Turner's in the mix Priyanka and
like Kevin's wife Danielle and like
their the Jay sisters and they're so
cute a reality show yeah totally look
have anything else you'd have one
I remember that that's vintage that is
what is that called like keeping up with
the Joneses like living Judas with Kevin
maybe it was living Jonas okay they
could have done better
yeah but I agree I feel like at pillow
doing arm is I couldn't be more
different but end of the day have the
same message which is just like
uplifting and bettering yourself totally
bu right I like it I like it too I can't
have both of them scream at me while I
work out yeah maybe Tony Robbins is so
inspiring to I know that's so cliche to
say but he really is he's never I've
never actually like listened to him take
everyone's word for it you know he's we
saw him once in person his presence is
so insane and he has so much charisma
like that man walks in a room and it's
just it's it's oozing but is it a
spiritual thing or is it just um like a
motivational I think it's it's almost in
the middle it's it's he makes you really
look at your life and take
accountability I think it's it's more
like it's very all in by Teddy ish did
you ever do all in no I want to try it I
feel like I could see you did I kind of
want to try it just to like do a whole
blog post on it you should I know
everyone keeps telling me I should
try it cuz I could listen you know five
pounds and just try but also I feel like
she's so successful in like in helping
people and like what she's done for it
like the proof is in the pudding like
when she shows those little pictures of
her Jasha where she was when she like
was so much heavier it's like it's crazy
how in shape she is now she looks
amazing and she works out on vacation
and for that reason I'm out on all in
but um I'm gonna try it I feel like I
should try it and like really do it for
like two months that would just be I
mean it would be interesting like for
your website and then also worst case
scenario you just like did something
really good for yourself for two months
yeah and like maybe you'll feel better I
I hope it's not so restrictive like I
don't want to count calories or anything
I have to look into it
have you ever done whole 30 no but but
you did keto for your wedding right yeah
I want to ask you about you know for
like three years now
um and I love it okay and cuz for me
just my my mentality right now I've been
trying to get off of it and just be more
like healthy all around but it's hard
for me because I'm literally like an
all-or-nothing person it's like I'm
either dieting and being so good I'm
strict etc or I'm eating everything in
sight what's your sign Scorpio Oh does
that make sense no but I'm not your
typical Scorpio okay so like cuz they're
all nuts and I'm pretty level-headed
okay but a little tad and that's aspyn
right a little sprinkle sprinkle um so I
loved like keto because it's like you
can eat only this group of food speaking
as much as you want so like for me that
works as opposed to like having to eat
like thinks more about so what you can
you not eat carbs no carbs yeah it's
Atkins and no alcohol yes you can have
alcohol you can have alcohol dependent
like vodka tequila has no carbs okay um
like wine champagne has more sugar so it
has a little bit of carbs but um you can
have a and it's high fat you know who
lost a lotta weight from that and has an
incredible Instagram page that everyone
should go check out is jenna jameson
memberid yes by the way her
autobiography good I think it's called
how to make love like a porn star it's
so good so read her autobiography and
then go look at her Instagram it's
called like jenna can't lose she has so
many keto tips that are
like the best that is so interesting and
know and I'm right like she did just was
odd way and she looks so good and I did
hear a mosquito but now you're so right
she learnt from what I love a celeb
autobiography oh this is the one this is
the one you want juice what are some of
your other top ones Janice Dickinson how
fun would a round table view with Janice
Dickinson and you and Claude yes if you
can make it happen
I'm putting it out there in the ether
Janice Dickinson autobiography is great
um Erika Jaynes was good hmm I could
have had a little more juice I could
have had a little more housewives juice
yeah I want some housewives juice um who
else Taylor Armstrong of housewives
throat one hers is good Kris Jenner has
a great autobiography she does yeah it's
all about the OJ Simpson case that's so
underrated yeah people needs it like
never how to make love like a porn star
though is a good one okay I'm gonna read
that I could see you in Game of Thrones
where IV do you read the Holly Madison
one yes I read the Holly that was a good
one that was a good one
I read on The Bachelor once too just
like what's a bachelor one should I read
uh Oh should you read um TBD TBD yes
well endorphins is cute but it's not
super battery it's more like single if
it like like gives us behind the scenes
of The Bachelor and you get oh there's
like the one by the this LA Times writer
but she wasn't like she just observed
so like Sean like from bachelor
contestants themselves
Amanda's writing one I want to say we
meet hers too yeah I want to read hers I
bet that one's good she's a cutie
she is a cutie next up so longe cancels
Coachella sets due to major production
delays less than a week before Solange
was set to appear on stage of Coachella
the singer has canceled her upcoming
sets due to unspecified quote major
production delays due to major
production delays Solange will
unfortunately no longer be performing at
this year's festival organizers worked
Sunday night on Twitter she sends her
sincerest apologies and looks forward to
performing at Coachella in the future so
lounges cancellation will apply to both
weekends of the festival Rolling Stone
has learned a rep for golden voice the
production company behind Coachella
prefer to request more information to
Solange Solange is Soak spokesperson a
representing stone to the best
organizers tweet out so they're all
referring each other to each other and
declined to comment further so I does
not commented on the cancellation as a
Sunday night prize Esteli this is weird
first of all it's crazy to cancel like
it makes sense okay if you're not ready
for this weekend fine but to cancel for
the following weekend like you could
have gotten right there's ulterior
motives there what sorts of product like
I feel like not that I ever pay
attention to what's going on a Coachella
but golden voice really does most of the
production you kind of just like show up
with your dancers and your costumes and
like ready to go
it feels very Lindsay Lohan circa you
know 2012 when she went to the hospital
for exhaustion ya know it feels like
there's more than the story and this
isn't the story at all like production
delayed I feel like she consisted in the
Jason right that it feels like she went
to jay-z and said this is the real issue
something more is gonna come out about
that I feel like my ass you either like
it's like when someone cancels a tour
for like whatever reason or maybe like I
don't know she's pregnant but that's why
be honest I didn't do Coachella a few
years ago maybe she's pregnant so you
never know they'll be exciting yeah I
don't know I look forward to hearing the
real reason why she's not performing are
you going no I'm not do I've only been
to Coachella once for ten minutes that
makes sense
I'm not like I feel when I went it was
it's not my thing I get it I get why
everyone's really treacherous Thanks it
just it seems like a lot of work it's so
much work cloudy and I went once two
years ago and it was so much work it was
so torturous we wound up actually having
a fun time despite it all and we're
going back this year this weekend Oh
that'll be fun and it'll be fun and
it'll be funny and we're going with such
a fun brand then we're actually really
excited about it yeah I love the outfits
and like last time we went we literally
decided like two days before and the
clothes of it all it's what's so crazy
and like I don't even know how we got
close in time are you doing like fur
your Instagram feed did you plan the
clothes so it's gonna be like the same
kind of aesthetic no because so I think
one day with two outfits we'll be in two
outfits will be but it's like I just
want each out I want each outfit to be
like a different moment themed like I
like one that's like really like girly
and clean II like ariana grande I see
screams and one that's like more like
country-western but then we're also
going to stagecoach so I don't have to
be super country like I can save all my
country looks for that perfect yeah and
that's really fun do you like kind of
music I don't that make sense I don't I
mean I get why people like it but I just
I'm more of like a bossa nova fan what's
that I was like wait today I like
fashion over at what
so bossa nova is like Brazilian jazz
music it's all if you ever watch my
Instagram stories it's usually in the
background oh my god country music I
don't know why I just never took to it
but he'd be a billion jazz music I'd you
know what my grandma loved it which is
I'm sorry I'm like a grandma so I'm like
listening to bossa nova well everyone's
at Coachella good for you like wonderful
put anyone else in her spot Solange like
maybe they'll bring someone else in yeah
they have to I feel like it's a maybe
Coachella manipulated the narrative so
they can get more pressed to Coachella
me maybe there's not enough tickets sold
maybe it's a Kris Jenner higher plan
maybe but it's like I feel like Solange
is someone who would contribute to
ticket sales like but maybe she's out
regardless so so they they're
manipulative a'right Kris Jenner right
oh and also I did while I was looking
for stories I saw a sad story about
Coachella like one of the workers like
fell to his death oh maybe this is like
something so that I didn't talk about
that story because there were two
Coachella stories and I chose this one
oh that's interesting
isn't it it really said it's the I off
what's really happening right hmm yeah
there's something weird there I feel
like there's something fishy yeah I hope
they bring in someone else cuz um
there's not that much music for me at
Coachella other than Kacey Musgraves you
should check her out okay that's what
everyone says I am gonna check her out
if you guys have any country
recommendations that I can start with
I'm a country version Kacey Musgraves
golden hour album okay it's your don't
hurt me - it's not like I'm muddy okay
it's um it's more like indie she's
performing at Coachella so like she's
crossing over and I think it's I've
never heard of anyone who doesn't like
her she really is for everyone Michael's
having a really big moment right now
with Billy Ray Cyrus's new song right
everyone's having a big moment it's an
exciting moment it's over and over and
over and over well he does his hair Wow
which takes 45 minutes so it's doesn't
stop I have to be honest I haven't heard
it yet because I've been living in a
game of Thrones cave okay well you gotta
listen to it
Michael will probably play it for you
after this Oh will you please yeah I
didn't mean to but then also Brooks and
Dunn came out with an album that's like
all clap they're like a country duo that
I don't even really listen to but like
they have a song with Casey so Casey's a
girl burning the pantsuit so it's like
if you couldn't agree with her okay I'm
gonna start with Casey you guys I think
that's the way to start I really think I
got a certain flow I don't hate country
music I just haven't found fire the
taste for it yeah cuz once you like one
you like em all okay cuz they are they
are similar I can admit that okay next
story really cute Kylie Jenner loves
styling her daughter her daughter stormy
Sarah that was such a New York accent
the water I love how this is like a
headline I know she Kylie likes to style
her daughter's hair yes but she she did
a whole hyperlapse on her Instagram
story of her doing Stormy's hair okay
and she had these captions where she's
like I'm not so good at it yet but I'm
learning and I'm loving I'm loving
learning how to do it and I just found
it to be very label at the end of the
day all she really did was like a
ponytail um but I feel like it's like
right now I'm learning how to cook and
it's so that eventually like I can
provide for myself and like my family
knock on wood but it's like I'll also
need to take a class one day to learn
how to do like French braids because I
know how to actually pretty good at hair
I could do my kids hair but it's like
you want to learn new things in order to
do them for your kids
I might outsource that I got to be
honest braids yeah I might call glam
squad for my daughter but it's like what
if it's just for school like you know
don't you want to just I might have
Michael learn how to do that yeah I wish
that would learn honey braids because
then he could do them guys tell Zack
needs to learn lymphatic drainage for
the face and French braids for your
future daughter I came in you don't know
how to do braids I do I know when I do
like regular braids but not French right
not bright not a--not mean you know
that's like two miles I know and it's
like o'clock like I can't practice
myself cuz it hurts your arm it hurts
your arms so but I feel like I could
definitely figure out for a child and
that'll be really fun yes and you could
always YouTube it too
yes you know or you could just throw a
wig on the kid right or you could always
just do a ponytail or you know like a
Clement braid right or
just regular braids the old-fashioned
way ya know or just go to dry bar get a
blowout and then say to the woman Oh
could you also get a French braid for
little Kate I would maybe do that but I
have a boycott against Schreiber and the
what last time I did go I went for
braids just like for cute French braids
boycott because I went for like first of
all there one time like they're just
terrible in general and like they don't
know what they're doing in like one time
I came home when I found purple shampoo
in my hair I was like I didn't even know
what that was and turns out it's for
true for blondes yeah I was just gonna
say I wouldn't put purple beans me then
but you know what I gave them chance
after chance then I went for just two
french braids okay and the girl did them
she didn't have to wash my hair or
anything she did them and they were like
so crooked and terrible and I never say
anything but this time I was like I'm
not going anywhere like this like do you
mind just like straightening it and
straightening the part and redoing them
so she did and from far away they looked
fine and so I left and then up close
it's like they were so like my hair was
so frizzy on top like they were oh it
was harp I took them out immediately I
literally flushed 40 dollars down the
toilet and now I'd never go back but as
you glance one the trick to dry bar is
you have to just get a rough dry blowout
that's the trick you can't go in for
like an updo or like like the BRIT like
you want to go in just for a rough dry
blowout and then either learn to do it
yourself on YouTube I think or if you
have a friend like someone that knows
how to braid really well yeah I think I
know I think I could learn I've never
really like applied myself yeah but I
think for I can't like I would be so
excited to do it yeah I like that
Kylie's daughters but you're like her
daughter's hair is really short - so
it's like makes it hard to put up yeah
how is she doing a ponytail she was
doing like hers like this short she was
doing it in like sections that's why I
took long cute yeah cute and it's fun to
learn
she says she keep mom do you watched
Kardashian's last night no cuz you were
flying and getting pizza no but tell me
what happened honestly was a really good
an interesting episode um and as I was
sitting there watching I was like does
act like this is an interesting episode
and then I watched him story and she was
like I think you're gonna like tonight's
episode it's really what was what was
the me like I just felt like
those episodes where there wasn't a
contrived storyline I'm not like we're
gonna do this prank I'm think it was
just like this is our life I don't like
the construct the contrived storylines
but I don't want to break so like the
one storyline was that chick Kanye had
said that she was moving to Chicago and
he said it publicly before him and kid
had spoken about it so it was like that
actually seemed to me like the contrived
storyline like like Connie has like time
to make drama for the show now see he's
like I'm he's into the show like I think
he thinks it's cool keeping up with
Kanye I love it as a part of it I love
it and then the other drama was like
Kourtney and Scott they're going on a
family vacation the whole like the whole
Kardashian clan to Bali and according to
know if she would invite Scott so Kim
came up with this plan to invite Scott
to their New York trip for SNL and
Kourtney would see that he can get along
with the family and it's good okay which
is exactly how it worked out and he got
invited on the big trips and it was
Sophia invited no but I like I've never
seen their relationship and I love it I
love that Sophia is going to make a
cameo on Keeping Up I think eventually
she would because first of all the proof
of the their relationship is in the
pudding like Scott has never been better
they've been together for a year there's
been no drama like I feel like she's so
good for him there's also this this
sexual tension between Kourtney and
Scott still oh my god
I don't even valuable I don't know no oh
my god I like when he was talking to her
last night I was like I felt like he was
just trying to keep himself from like
getting annoyed with her and like be
like getting fed up with her because
it's impossible to talk to her so you
don't know I don't think there's
anything do you don't think she wants
him at all I feel like she doesn't she
just doesn't want him like to be with
other people but she doesn't know what
she doesn't want to take it on herself
okay you know and I feel like for him
it's like he always thought he wanted to
be with her cuz I was like the easier
path but now he's realizing like there's
so much more happiness out there for him
okay you don't think they're gonna get
back together never and I feel like now
they look at each other and they're like
how are we ever even together and do you
think Sophia's jealous of Kourtney no
like I feel like she's you don't I don't
think she's jealous of her like
obviously she wants like and she wants
like more access and whatnot but like
she I think she has what she wants you
know Kourtney has what she wants she has
a family and and Sophia has like a great
relationship with Scott and like they
have their own like little family
Kourtney has never looked better though
okay
but like she looks like Sofia I love I
know if she doesn't they say what the
job of like all the different dynamics
of the whole thing that's that's what I
think I'm obsessed with is it's like an
onion I know there's so many dynamics
and it's like when you heard Scott and
Sophia were dating it's like that's the
craziest thing ever how's the family
kind of come back from this and now one
year later it's just like the most
normal thing I always the best thing for
him it's crazy it's crazy the only thing
that they never came back to him was
like blac Chyna and that never but
they've never mentioned it again and
right it's like it never happened
I know but I feel like they still deal
with drama on the side toes like don't
talk we need to see more of Rob I know
oh that's like a whole other thing that
anyways it was it was a key depa soda
recommended I got a watch yeah it's on
TiVo we'll watch club speaking of
Kourtney sorry Poosh Poosh We Need to
Talk
have you checked it out I've checked it
out I get this really checks out your
website you get her newsletter Wow here
it is I I think that it's an interesting
thing for her to launch like if I were
consulting her I would tell her to
launch something really niche like you
remember how she always talked about
avocado pudding yeah yeah I always saw
her launching something like like that
or like a baby food that's so healthy
where it's like the product like a food
product I think that that a Content site
is always a good idea I think everyone
should have their own content site
contents obviously very important as you
know but it's a lot of work I mean you
have to it's it's everyday she hasn't
seem too keen on words that's what
that's why I think a product might have
been the move mm-hmm you know like
something because she's so healthy I
always want to know why I live in her
cabinet did you watch her boat wake up
tutorial no was it good
nobody's interesting like if you want to
watch what she's doing it's like a lot
of natural nature beauty yeah so you I
almost wanted something like that from
right then product speak to her but she
worked with remember how she did the
manuka honey
cream yeah like I thought she was gonna
come I always thought I always think
they're content marketing so like
talking about products before they
launch it and I thought she was gonna
come out with the product but I have to
tell you I do like the name yeah you
know that's a nickname for the youngest
yeah no one likes the name I like the
name I think it's too I don't mind the
name yeah I think it's like it actually
it's so something that we would do it's
like we all have these weird any themes
for each other and it's like I would
maybe launch a natural beauty website
called Sneetches honestly ah not the
worst idea
Oh daddy except maybe not um maybe not
natural beauty maybe just like you know
chemical infused beauty that's okay I
like it I'm into it but I've been trying
like a lot of new beauty products
recently and what's the standout star oh
well first off my favorite line and this
was intended to be an A but I don't even
mean it that way is kobbari lovely know
that you love Campari and I just started
using their natural deodorant which is
actually it's just a really kinda baby
wearing their natural deodorant right
now really okay so what happened was a
few weeks ago I you see she was like my
regular deodorant with chemicals and
then it like wasn't strong enough I
started using Zack C odor and like men's
doing for so long and like I still felt
like I was sweating through and I was
like even with all these chemicals like
I'm it's not even like I'm B I'm so
immune to all of it and like it can't be
good for me and I'm I know it's right by
your boob and dry fatik and I like
talking too much about this stuff but I
was like there's something to be said
about natural deodorant and Claudia had
started using the cope re one cuz they
send it to us and she was like I love it
it smells so good so two weeks ago I
switched natural deodorant and I'm I
already feel so much better like yeah
and I don't I love the way that Co part
everything smells it cuz it smells like
coconuts but I don't feel like I smell
at all anymore and like and I also don't
feel like I'm ruining my body and if you
are interested in Kapaa rees coconut
deodorant we have a code for you go to
cope re Beauty calm sighs toast to save
five dollars off your first do tour in
order when you subscribe that's cope re
KO PA RI beauty.com slash toast cope re
beauty.com slash shows but i love if
you're at Kapaa beauty concise shows i
really love their rose toner
love the rose tonight you cannot go
wrong with their lip gloss
it's that's ogres thing that got me into
cope re the lipgloss is amazing it's
amazing I don't have the tinted colors I
just I love everything that they're
doing in out including children and I
feel like I'm doing something good for
myself but then um other Prado I told
you I got the Jade roller Jade was great
and you know what I don't think I've
been using it right and I literate the
first time I did it I like just put on
my phone I think I gave myself had I
have a picture of Barbie and I drew all
over Barbie's face of the ways to do it
and I'm gonna post it on Instagram oh my
god perfect it's it's like the perfect
like it's her face straight on and you
can see what the arrows go and I got the
rose quartz roller instead of Jade
because it's like it Cleopatra you stir
it you throw the difference in they're
there they're just they're different
stones I mean I personally like the rose
quartz roller because I feel like my job
it matches my feet oh I just like the
whole thing with it and then you use it
with an oil it's magical it is okay I
have to have to get more skilled at it
also what are your thoughts on CBD I
love CBD I used to go to bed at 2:00
a.m. every night after years like you
would work in like watch TV I would wear
just I would work from 11:00 to 2:00 in
the morning okay all the time and so I
and I used to bartend when I was first
starting blogging so I would get home
and 11 goat about it too and I got in
this habit of of staying up until 2:00
so I just started implementing CBD like
a year ago and I am in bed by 9:45 so
how do you consume it there's so many
different ways to convert it Ivan as
last week we started experimenting with
okati a nightly cuts of chocolates um
and I'm figuring it out okay I got one
chocolate that was good but I only eat
half and I didn't feel a thing
what kind of chocolate was the brand
what was the brand
do you know it I don't but I fancy and
then I'd also bought another chocolate
from clean market and it was the most
disgusting thing I ever ate I couldn't
no you don't want it to be and I
couldn't even I threw it away you but I
like to brush my teeth and then get in
bed and do it because then I'm just
winding down so what do you have a
chocolate I have okay there's two things
I have I have like um it's like a
dropper okay and it's mint and so I put
it in my mint tea like I'll do like a
big huge thing of mint and then put mint
oil in it that sounds nice and then I
also I have a little it's not a vape
it's like a little it's like a lot like
an e-cig kind of like a beep kinda and I
do one puff of that and I am out like a
light it is crazy where do you get that
it's called bee blow and it's gold so
it's like really cute like it's some I
even got like this pink ashtray because
I've never been a smoker ever like I
don't like pot not that there's anything
wrong with it I just don't like it
angry so I have like this this acrylic
little pink ashtray and I have my gold
pen on it and I do one puff and I'm out
Wow okay I've been living so wrong you
gotta try it I don't know why sleep is
the most healing thing you can do I
really is I hope for me it's like she
got away yeah you got away and if I'm in
bed if I get a full eight and a half
hours of sleep I am so much nicer to my
husband like so much nicer so I think
it's worth it okay well that I feel like
that's my next that's the next frontier
for me okay is sleepy sleepy deep
because it's like I feel I'm a beauty
front like I'm doing what I you know you
look amazing like and there's only so
much you can do actually my next stop
for beauty is to get Botox and my crow's
feet have you never had Botox before I
think I'd go top now three times on my
forehead look that you need it on your
crow's feet you look very very young
looking I mean we smile but I'm always
like oh I'm just like
by the other day like my makeup gives it
like live okay and but it's like that is
that's a big next up because the more
places you do it the more places that it
will force your wrinkles elsewhere you
know true true and you want to make sure
I already told you this you go to an
artist that's gonna lift the eyes and
stead a droopin yes doctor wonder what's
your name dr. taryn easy she's a
wonderful she does uh we found different
Real Housewives of New York
oh yeah those women look wonderful I
think it looks LuAnn Ramona so good so
good
um okay so that other than that then I
feel like mentally CD DS CP guy's
amazing
okay cool that's the lesson for today
but we sell more Christmas for you but
our fifth and final story is that
McKenzie Bezos is set to become the
fourth the world's fourth wealthiest
woman following her divorce from Amazon
founder Jeff Bezos fourth richest woman
in the world she will be worth at least
thirty five billion dollars after
receiving a quarter of these doses
Amazon shares that will give her a four
percent stake of Amazon according to a
court filing pending approval of their
divorce McKenzie Bezos will be the 23rd
richest person in the world on the
Bloomberg billionaires index bloomberg
reported late Thursday the richest woman
in the world is L'Oreal heiress Francois
Betancourt Myers with a net worth of
fifty three point seven billion
according to Bloomberg the second
wealthiest woman is Alice Walton the
billionaire daughter of Walmart's
founder third place is a co-owner of a
candy Empire and then fourth places now
Mackenzie Bezos congratulations I feel
like she's gonna have a line out the
door of Cedars oh my god totally or I
feel like she's gonna start a company
like a charity you know she should she
should do cut some kind of company I
feel like when you have that much money
it's like something something that keeps
your mind young yeah boy she'll start
like a business that's like empowering
women or something what do you like who
she like who do you know maybe she's an
investor in Poosh yeah that's where it's
all coming that's so funny well I mean
so she didn't get half it doesn't seem
it sounds that sounds like she got a
quarter I feel like it's fair but I
think it's like it's you say it seems
fair it seems fair
I mean she seems she's doing okay she'll
be okay you know
yeah but this story this whole saga has
just been I so I'm not surprised though
I have to say I'm not surprised he had
an affair because it's with he has so
much power so much money we see that so
often right I'm not shocked right you
know yeah
but then like the texts and the pictures
and it's just like so shameful like the
fact that he is like one of the most if
not the most powerful man in the world
and like people have pictures of his
weiner that's crazy I haven't seen his
weiner I was able to come out but they
when the who leech detects the brother
but he also had like a new photos of him
I don't know how his weiner yeah
huh and they were like threatening to
release them and it's just like this is
Jeff baseless you guys like if it can
happen to him it could happen to anyone
or how do you not know it was like a
Kris Jenner great grand scheme how do we
know it's really his weiner what if it's
a fake Weiner that's really big right he
didn't maybe it doesn't so bad I'm in a
real photo so crazy though like the
weight like Jeff Bezos like you know
whatever conferences he goes to it was
like all of you on the room would have
seen his penis like that's so 2019 but
I'm releasing photos of your Weiner if
we break up I have a whole rolodex of
them on file different ingles you never
know which angle I'm gonna release Dan
Savage at least you'll know who did it
you won't be like goodnight uh crazy but
I'm I'm happy this is coming to an end
for her I want happiness for her you go
and she deserves like this has been like
I'm sure how many kids I think they have
like three kids they have like a handful
and are they older younger middle-aged
like not middle-aged but like twelve
aged I'm making this out that this just
seen the intern was rough like we didn't
have this growing up to happen to grow
up and to have your dad's penis on like
not well not the app but the threat of
penis like this I know so just your
parents getting divorced in the public
and your dad it's a water and his text
you read those texts yeah I think
actually that was more marital yeah a
little awkward a little awkward I like I
don't I can't even like when we get to
read those
to show you guys pink range yeah you
know ruff I'm happy that that this is
coming to an end for all of them yes
y'all need a vacation I think they need
to I think they can afford it yeah right
now they can they couldn't before
but now she can anyways those are the
precise stories that you need to know it
was a very quiet weekend apparently I
didn't miss much while I was just were
you off social media as well I really
was because nothing was really happening
for me on social mean every time I check
my phone I was like this is just like
stressing me out the fact like I was
like I have pictures suppose I don't
feel like posting them so I just kept
like throwing my phone away Saturday and
Sunday to is the worst day to post on
the feed you think yeah 100% oh well
it's half Ashley Saturday interests
Saturday Saturday just Instagram doesn't
exist to me I don't agree I take a day
off usually what do you thinks the best
time to post I love a Wednesday okay and
then a Monday in the morning is great oh
this Monday morning out okay I'm go
something I have something ready to go
yeah being so lazy I couldn't even press
share yeah no I need me the caption that
always just stops and your captions are
always very witty though but but it's so
much pressure and then like I didn't I
feel like when I can't think in the
caption I just liked okay so should we
ask them what kind of caption they
should do like well describe you okay
it's two pictures of me from Thursday
night like crying unbelievably glad her
in the first photo I'm looking to the
side and the second photo Mike so it
could be like a before like a me versus
you know user so then I was like
thinking of captions and I was like this
is coming too hard and that's always
when it's not worth it we need ideas um
but speaking of Instagram and the flow
um your flow is a premium at you're the
queen of flow and you taught us
everything that we know that's such a
nice compliment you're like I love I
love Lightroom now and I just like I
still can't like use the same preset for
every photo I know that's the key to
like real premium well I I get that
because it's like I want to use the
preset or the filter that's best for
each individual photo so agree either
they might not look the best that they
could but separately they look great and
together they look fine as long as you
up the blacks and up the white yes and
you're seeing a lot of that on the feet
it's usually okay and you stick to
similar colors
yes that's what are you yeah yours is no
your I gotta say like it reminds me of
the song a Barbie world what is it like
lot
two different colors it's very like
flamboyant and festive you it's a
feel-good feed okay it doesn't make you
feel bad about yourself you feel like
you're like living life like happy color
very toasty
thank you it's like whatever colors in
the picture that's the caller ID century
that's like my feet it's just any color
yeah at any time
I still talk about that dress you order
your bachelor party that was the pink
latex I can't get over that I'll never
get over they loved that I would wear it
but I feel like I can't wear it after
you wore it so well it's doing it an
injustice no I feel like you could wear
it you look so good in it no anyway they
would like the fact your hair everything
was I think you did a ponytail right I
did yeah and I didn't actually I wish I
had done like a more uh slicked-back
ponytail it was perfect was like a messy
pony but it all worked out maybe you
have to bring that picture like bump it
up like that's not true yeah I couldn't
seem to do that a little bit more like
you know sometimes you got a recycle
recycle or it's like I took like 20
pictures not just I have other ones like
I could post a different one but it's
like then I get stuck with like how do I
make this seem like it's just part of my
feed right now more reek Wando your feet
put the pictures that give you joy get
rid of the ones that don't you know yeah
do in every area of your life okay this
is this could change my life I'm excited
okay now I'm going to take some toaster
questions for you because we all need
your help if you had to give a
bare-bones skincare routine for a
broke-ass [ __ ] what would you recommend
like drugstore yeah okay so I love clean
and clear oxygenating moisturizer I
can't go wrong I've been using it
forever
sometimes they're sold out so get the
white bottle okay I don't like Cetaphil
a lot of people use Cetaphil and he sees
it as younger yeah it's very drying for
the skin I if I was dead broke I would
actually go and I think I might have
said this on the show before I would go
to like Whole Foods or a health food
store and buy a huge bottle of extra
virgin organic cold-pressed olive oil
I would cleanse with it and I would use
that after your moisturizer last Wow and
I would really put it under the eyes all
those on nutrients of the olive oil is
gonna seep into your face take it down
to your nipples the other day
Jenner was like she did like a Instagram
story I was so proud she said every
night before she goes to bed she douses
herself and oil I'm a huge believer that
oil is is like the key to you if you're
not looking like a wet sloppy mess when
you go to bed you're not doing it right
you know what I mean yeah no I'm not
doing it right yeah you want to be wet
okay like you want your satin pillowcase
to absorb something I just started using
a satin pillowcase it's life-changing
yeah I feel like I'm doing some like I
really cuz I when I would wake up I
would really see like lines on my face I
imagine eight hours I know I've really
got and now I have to get like right now
we have like four pillows and only one
of them has a satin pillowcase because I
was like I'll try it
don't let your husband have it no but
maybe I'll get it for all four pillows
right I can never wind up on a non satin
pillowcase true a natured satin not silk
I've just learned from nine silk I know
but it's I know it's similar
okay satin because satin absorbs less
product this is what I learned from a
Barbara stone so yeah I would do I would
get a huge bottle of olive oil keep it
next to your your sink don't use wipes
it's it's pulling on the face like
makeup light yeah I feel like a lot of
people use wipes to get their makeup use
oil okay it's just gonna wash it off to
an oil cleanse and then try that
cleaning clearer and put more oil on
your face and also the massage I can't
tell you enough with the oil but as long
as you have a huge thing of olive oil
you should be good okay that's good
advice how's your jaw what has like such
a saga every time I come on here nothing
happened
I just I just felt like the metal in my
face was blocking my lymphatic drainage
oh my god so I got the metal out okay as
a very quick surgery and they went
through my mouth so you can't see any
scars but I am very swollen so I've been
doing a lot of facial manipulation
interesting when did you do that I did
this like a week and a half ago Wow yeah
that's like very short that makes sense
it feels very short and a fun fact I
learned is that the mouth heals faster
than any area of the body because the
stem cells so the cut in my mouth is
like
already healed wow that's crazy very
cool what's more important for skincare
vitamin C or retinol I mean I think
that's III don't want to give a blanket
answer on that because everyone has
different skin vitamin C to me is like a
must have in the morning you want to put
it on in the morning before your
sunscreen I really like dr. Dennis's but
they have some vitamin C at health food
stores that are like eight bucks that
are great and it's a cream it's a cream
but dr. Janice is a serum okay I really
like his sturm uh he's any vitamin C
personally I would pick vitamin C over
retinol because I feel like with retinol
if you don't use it right and you get
one speck in the Sun or even lights like
this the hyperpigmentation comes out
right now for the night okay look he has
like a forty step oh really
who has morning deaths sometimes
honestly him and when I get sent product
he puts his sticky fingers in it and
that's so bad he has an eye cream he's
using his index finger so do you guys
travel with all this stuff and if so
then do you have to check luggage you do
put in your luggage it's not a lot of
stuff in fact I'll show it on my
Instagram story it's just like this much
it's little tiny bottles with if you
make it in little tiny yeah you and you
can just go to the drugstore and get
those little travel-size bottles and put
it it and it's like so productive it
takes five sec I'm just like I'll just
take the whole bottle and throw it away
if I get in trouble and doing a skincare
routine when you're on flight because
you're art you don't have Wi-Fi usually
yeah it's so great like I just go to the
airport with no makeup on and do an
in-flight skin routine what do you do
definitely a sheet mask okay like first
two people look at you like you're so
crazy I don't care
they probably do I don't care I mean
I've you know I just don't care right no
totally
sometimes the stewardess they're like oh
what mask is that oh yeah the stewardess
get it you got they totally good it's
like your fellow plane goers yeah they
probably don't love me but it's like
it's better than other people who are
like farting in yeah I'm not I'm not
farting right yesterday this guy's balls
were like spread on Michael like I'm not
doing that I'm just doing my in-flight
skincare routine okay so you do
math sheet masks and then I wanted more
when we go to Coachella this weekend
like ah I wanted to even come into it
and do it your makeup on the plane
because it's not worth it it's a waste
makeup yeah I actually rise out because
I have to I'll be spray tan so I'm gonna
have to wear a spray tan on the plane
which is like gross but by the time I
guess I just saw a tan okay they'll be
perfect it's the perfect time to let its
highly it yes so don't do too much oil
if you have a spray tan see that's this
is like I'll be able to do anything yeah
that's what I was just gonna say you
can't do a sheet mask with a spray tone
I can't do anything oh I didn't do a
sheet mask yesterday excited a spray tan
okay me and then I'll do it on the way
back I just did a lot of vitamin C and
like a thick moisturizer okay I don't do
anything when I am hard to be a girl
you're like do I give the man in here
first or the spray to it so when you put
this right hand into the mix it
complicates everything it's it's so it's
like the meme with all the mathematical
guys what do you do first
no and it's like you can't do any of
these things with a spray tan but the
spray tan covers up all these things
that you need like you do all these
things but it's pretty handy like spray
time you lose ten pounds in one second
right so it's like you don't even need
to join the face because the face is
looking slim and the woman who's brave
hands our faces contour them but yeah
that's a good one yeah what that's a
good one it's a good tan yeah okay who
are people that you follow for style
inspiration style inspiration that's
such a good question I mean I love the
Kardashian style because I feel like
they have access to the best of the best
in every single area so they're gonna be
so on the pulse like there with the best
stylist I think her name is Dani
something they have access to the best
hair the best makeup so in knowing that
it's not necesarily I'm obsessed with
their style I'm obsessed with the fact
that they're on the pulse of what's
happening right it's so I would always
say I look to them to see what's you
know what's up and coming yeah like
everyone was making fun of Kim wearing
sweats you know two years ago and now
every single person isn't sweat haha
so you have to look at how they're so
ahead of it and then I'm really inspired
by a lot of European bloggers like I
love to look at what's happening over
there I feel like they have a different
style yeah interesting you're so right
about the Kardashians they don't even
realize it but they're on the polls
right it's like where everything is
going you can like
in the future of fashion it's true and
you look at stuff that came more like
years ago and you remember thinking like
at the time like oh that was a weird
choice but now when you look at it it's
like no then that was everywhere but
remember bike shorts came out everyone
who I hate I'm still waiting for those
basketball shorts she was wearing a
member last season she was wearing high
fastball shorts and like a they'll come
they'll come on right now
they'll come but it's it's so true space
outfit uh-huh they'll come even though
all those like bomb on dresses when she
wore them when she like when she started
dating Kanye like that seems like it's
like a staple now they'll it's odd all
comes crazy who's the most motivational
guest you and Michael have had on the
show for sure you guys we're gonna be on
your show tomorrow you guys are coming
on our show tomorrow excited we're gonna
do a foursome yes possibly singing
Little Mermaid again I can't wait
yeah and we're gonna get I want to know
like you guys's Beauty wedding skin diet
tips I'm gonna get specific oh that's
good that'll give me time to premiere
it's I'm always like thinking off the
top of my head but I need I'll take
stock of my probably we need to know I
want the most specific of specifics
I've been getting more like ice
literally like this is so hard but but I
used to literally use like Zach's
shampoo like there's something like some
things I'm so crazy about that's good
though that's balance but then recently
I guess coz of my wedding I was like you
know what I want to start like just
having a little bit of shinier hair so
like I'll do a hair mask and I got like
a nicer shampoo and then I went to the
house and broad PR closet the other day
and I like filled up on everything that
I don't have so now I use Kerastase and
I'm fancy as [ __ ] but purple shampoo
purple shampoo and I like I never even
had like a proper face wash in the
shower cuz I just use like dub shampoo
and that really always works but
sometimes I really needed an exfoliator
like because do you ever over moisturize
and then like that causes problems yeah
try um there's two things to try Kate
Somerville makes an awesome exfoliator
it's called a exfoliate okay it's smell
Alyssa cute names
that's so good and it's like a little
facial in the shower and then dr. Dennis
also does I just love his products it's
not like salons or anything I just love
his products is an exfoliating
moisturizer so it's working together so
you're exfoliating as you moisturize
interesting I'm like so basic I like
need to get isolated I bought say knives
we can't do say knives that's right what
wait I told you about saying oh I didn't
I don't think so
I was remembered you didn't tell me what
happened okay so st. I could have sworn
I told you this I didn't know
okay so st. Ives is the one exfoliator
you do not want to use you can Google
st. everyone Google st. Ives there's a
whole thing about the beads and them
they're plastic
so you're rubbing plastic against your
skin whereas like another exfoliator
it's the rough texture is from something
that's like a natural google st. Ives
apricot scrub recall I thought I told
you that now you know I would remember
that and that's so many one thing we
can't have seen eyes that's the only
thing okay I throw it away
I'm sorry know what I like I literally
got it last week so I've only used it
the one I've done like 20 blog posts on
st. Ives and out there eight is it the
Abraham yes I used it all the time by
the way in high school so no yeah it's
like wow this pistachio forever miss so
I remember when I got a sample of it in
like Seventeen magazine like and I used
it and then I bought it and it's like
everyone must have got in that sample
because everyone's getting it oh yeah I
it was a body wash oh they had it like
for like but me like for your butt like
where you would use it on like your box
simple I like use the whole thing and
then there was a recall on it because it
was plastic microbeads oh my god
yeah that's crazy okay thank God I
mentioned my god that makes me so happy
that we talked about that no totally and
I'm sure there's so many who let you see
nice because it's just like when you
think of exfoliator you think you've
seen eyes oil cleansing try oil
cleansing if you could only use one line
of products that's like I always think
about this in terms of like clothes see
if you only wear like one dozen I really
like Elemis they have a great cleansing
balm okay which is amazing and then it's
affordable and they have a superfood oil
they have all the stuff and it's
affordable ooh sounds good you walk into
your kitchen starving for lunch or
dinner what's the quickest thing you
make healthy both one healthy one not
healthy I eat so many eggs I'm gonna
turn into an egg is so definitely so
for you so many eggs I love eggs so
probably two eggs and I am obsessed with
these things called cauliflower thins
they taste like bread oh and it's it's
like one carb and one gram of fiber yeah
so I do like four of those in toast them
with like avocado mayonnaise and a piece
of prosciutto this is like kind of
technical but this I just have all the
stuff so I just throw it on and then put
an egg on it and like some hot sauce so
good yeah it's like my favorite meal
right now cool what are the best things
to do to your skin months prior to your
wedding well you would know you're
looking glowy
like I feel like there's nothing like
you can do months prior unless you like
if you're gonna get a facial like do it
early I never wound up getting one cuz I
didn't it was cutting it too close but
it's just like start hydrating now but
then I felt like the week and also stop
drinking that's the best thing you could
do yeah but the problem you having a
little drink less is it your wedding is
so stressful and there's so many
different personalities and dynamics and
you want to look good in your wedding
dress that I feel like it's it's like
for me like I yes but I think on all
counts drinking the worst I probably was
drank 90% like starting I got married in
Fabio were starting in August I really
like cut down on drinking and that
helped me from a beauty standpoint it
helped me mentally because like when I'm
hungover I can't do anything lights on
until 8:00 stop me from feeling now even
if it's just like one or two glasses of
wine I just feel like a little slower
the next day and I guess maybe I won't
want to work out or maybe I won't eat
well so it helped me truly eat better
too and it keeps you just like hydrate
it was really i saw a major difference
so I would say like cut down I would
never say stop drinking because you know
you know add tons of ice I've been doing
a champagne with tons of ice like to
water it down oh that's good yeah or any
way like wine with the tons about tons
of ice and do it in like a huge wine
goblet to be absurd no smart put a sheet
mask on on the plate and just take oh my
look is like you'll probably drink more
cards water than wine totally you feel
like you're drinking wine and you drink
it slower and you don't get like you
know to let that's actually the
see the ice that's come out of this show
for me personally wow that could change
things for a special icon vacation I
always want to be drinking but don't do
like a little ice I'm talking about like
a likes to the brain so much ice great
great tip okay I'm gonna take one more
question
whoo how can toasters fix the texture of
their skin without going breakup
bankrupt I would add one thing I would
invest in if you have texture issues is
a good exfoliator I would definitely
recommend that but if you're gonna use
and exfoliate or make sure you're
wearing sunscreen in a hat because the
exfoliator is gonna strip the skin so
that's really important okay but
honestly I think I'm gonna keep going
back to this because I think it's like a
babes on a budget tip that I would have
liked that I did apply in college in
high school is oil right get the oil get
a huge absurd bottle from Kirkland like
Costco you know I'm talking about yeah
but then what do you do when if you like
your face is like nice and oily cuz I
love some over moisturize and like I
don't mind looking oily to then in
pictures I look super oily do it at
night so so you're cut you're going home
you're taking your makeup off with the
oil you're putting your moisturizer in
your eye cream on and then you're
putting more oil on and then you wake up
and you do it take it to the tits
Caroline iron says that take it all the
way down here and you're gonna wake up
super dewy and plump because of the oil
I'm gonna do it tonight let's see if I
look at print tomorrow like orgeous
actually I probably will honestly you
know I may about your skin that's so
amazing it doesn't look like you go on
the Sun I I don't go in the Sun a lot
because I don't enjoy it okay which is
doing am like you're looking like I'm
from oh and I'm getting older it's like
I stay out of like I i'll wear sunscreen
and like do that because i know it's
like when you're younger it's like I
don't wear sunscreen I want to get a tan
but now it's like I I will do it because
I know it's good for me your look like
your skin tone is even thank you it
looks like surgeon nation yeah I'm gonna
go buy that well foundation jeez I
normally use Mac mixed with a little it
cosmetics sometimes I like a Borean day
cream but right now I'm wearing cover FX
it looks really good it does yeah like
what
out out - Nick nice glowy tone well on
that note thank you so much for being
here thank you so much for sharing your
wisdom with us yeah well you guys are
coming on tomorrow so I don't have
specifics all your product I will I'm
gonna be late and I'm gonna think about
like what's important like what couldn't
I live job you know yes um yeah and so
we'll be back tomorrow for a one-year
anniversary episode Claudia will be here
it'll be a fun day we'll be opening our
merge short with our best sellers and a
few new toasty items for our one-year
anniversary and we'll just be reflecting
on the past year and what it's meant to
us including all of you so thank you for
being here today thank you for being
here this year we will see you tomorrow
and I will see you tomorrow
thank you for helping everyone follow
you at the skinny confidential and I
have to tell you I bought a sweater you
did yes it's gray so cute it's the TMT
one of the sorority spent you're part of
this heart it's so cute Thanks oh and it
matches the flow
it matches the flow that's key so we'll
see you tomorrow everyone have a good
one
you